well the person that I've covered who I
probably admire the most was Mike
Mansfield the former Democratic leader
of the Senate and our longtime
Ambassador to Japan he was a remarkable
individual who well into his 90s was
current on public affairs and invariably
wise in his comments I'd love to know
what Mike Mansfield things we ought to
do about Iraq and other issues today
well thinking about this presidential
election coming up I think the issue
that will be on my mind is which if any
of these people prepared to tell the
American people the hard choices that we
reading face as a country and build the
degree of confidence that would enable
the people to make that choice it's
going to be a very tough presidency and
it's going to take a remarkable person
to prevail in it and I hope we find that
kind of leadership